da kommen so richtiges plastik zeuge an
siehst du das der funkelt hier sieht man
also damit nicht echt überrascht hätte
ich nicht gedacht gute gute ware
sagen wir so jung jetzt nur einer komme
und mich fragen wie viel das sein auto
bei dem jetzt sehe ich aber was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut
eigentlich kann im internet auch wieder
hinsetzen oder ja heute nach ein
bisschen längerer zeit glaube ich mal
wieder ein wisch video erwartet sonst in
kürzeren abständen gewohnt sagen wir mal
so und das heutige video muss man sagen
entsteht auch nur weg euch ich habe
nämlich diesen wunsch ab und zu mal in
den kommentaren gelesen und zwar haben
viele kommentiert alex macht doch mal
ein eis taufrisch produkte das kommt auf
also die sachen dann bestellt sind da
noch nicht alle da und alex bestellt
doch mal gold produkte bzw echtes gold
bei mensch das habe ich einmal gelesen
und das hatte viele likes und dann habe
ich mir so anguckt was sie denn genau
meinen und habsburg so echtes gold
eingegeben und da kam halt viele sachen
die also vergoldet sind natürlich ist es
kein echtes gold aber davon sind jetzt
viele sachen angekommen und ich schauen
wir uns heute mal an ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich glaube ich selber jetzt nicht
unbedingt auf die idee gekommen das
machen bei ich stelle mir andere sparten
deutlich interessanter vor aber ich sag
ja mal schreibt eure ideen und so in die
kommentare
deswegen macht heiß war und vielleicht
wird es ja auch ganz interessant wer
weiß was in kommentaren gelesen hat frau
dass du dich ab jetzt alex vision soll
haben wir auch schon mal drunter
ja auf jeden fall was man erst mal sagen
muss wir haben die halt pakete bekommen
daher gibt immer dieses paket willst du
das was ist dass ich war es nicht es ist
dass lachse in meinem briefkasten als
wäre irgendwie wachs drauf ausgelaufen
so wie früher da war das ja so bei den
brief geheimnissen so da haben die da so
ein wachs stempel darüber gemacht meiste
damit man es nur einmal öffnen konnte
also wir haben
grauen verpackungen sondern gelbe
verpacken warum das so ist ich weiß es
nicht wenn ihr es wisst schreibt gerne
in die kommentare
ich würde sagen wir packen mal hier das
erste das habe ich schon ausgepackt weil
ich mir unsicher war was das ist das
kommt aus luxemburg das kommt gar nicht
aus china dass sie kommen aus china
das auf und das auch aber dieses wieso
kommt es da nicht aus also es ist auf
jeden fall relativ hochwertig eingepackt
nur ich frage mich halt wirklich der
bestellt sich denn so was
wofür ist das sind ja das soll heißen
goldbarren seien
und bevor wir da jetzt weitermachen wir
schauen uns erst mal die ganzen produkte
in der app an die ich da bestellt habe
ich zeige euch die mal eben so fangen
wir mal hiermit an zwei euro das ist das
was hier liegt gold will gm gold war
souvenir coins also not ist das deutsche
übersetzung das ist nur ein dekorativer
kein echtes gold bitte verstehen
sozusagen glaube ich und deutsche
kommentare vom steffen sieht sehr echt
aus super replikat super ware sie toll
auslieferungen in der gewohnten zeit
qualität sehr gut was macht ihr dann ist
ehrlich man könnte ja auch mal ein video
machen wo man damit zum juwelier geht
und dass nur so hier informanten sondern
hört hier oder hier habe ich noch einen
ring bestellt in gold bei diamond 14 kg
gold bringen und wahrscheinlich wieder
sehr schöner damen bringen
aber es gibt halt wirklich also kann ich
auch verstehen es gibt damen die
bestellen sich diesen ring bayerischen
vision ich ja sowieso nicht deutschland
kriegt ihr marie und sagt jetzt echt da
habe ich dann auch gemacht und dann habe
ich hier noch nie was das hier genau
ruby diamond ein bisschen anders und
noch ein paar andere sachen also wir
packen das was mal aus ich will ja auch
nicht zu lange drumherum lagern hier
haben wir schon den ring
ok interessant zwei mal bestellt nee das
was anderes credit suisse als letztes
hatten wir jetzt hier dieses paket mit
dem ausgelaufenen wachs drauf und was da
drin ist also das hier sind jetzt die
viele sachen die ich bestellt hat
an sich ich bin jemand ich habe absolut
keine ahnung was echtes gold ist was
eine echte rolex ist was eine fake rolex
ist ich weiß nicht auf dem gebiet kenne
ich mich aus also wenn mir jetzt jemand
sagen würde alex hier das ist 2000 euro
wert würde ich es vielleicht sogar
glaube deswegen ist es jetzt an der zeit
dass hier mal auszupacken sommer hier an
würdest du jetzt erkennen dass das fake
ist wenn du es nicht wissen würde ist ja
ich habe mich auch nie mit so was
befasst keine ahnung krieg dass ich sie
nicht raus oder wie kann man dem hammer
so geht's doch sei es an den ball er
macht das hinterzimmer
also ich weiß es nicht aber nichts
kaputt gegangen also verträgt keine
schäden von sich leute wenn ihr euch
damit auskennt an die goldexperten
schreibt doch in die kommentare
würdet ihr jetzt hier direkt erkennen
dass das fake ist ich mich wirklich so
machen wir weiter
hier mit dem ersten ring und zwar das
ist der gold diamantenring deshalb ganz
klar den damen regnet oder steht er mir
auch sieht man das so früher diese ringe
aus dem kaugummiautomaten kennst du die
noch ja also wir waren ja wirklich
schrott da hat man auch sofort gemerkt
da ist nix aber dieser hier komplett
sogar soweit also ich bin echt
überrascht ich hatte gedacht da kommen
so richtiges plastik zeuge an siehst du
das der funkelt hier sieht man uns also
da will ich jetzt echt überrascht hätte
ich nicht gedacht gute gute wahl
sagen wir so zwei euro kann man nicht
mehr kann kannst du der einen oder
anderen dame nach
so dann haben wir hier den nächsten ring
das sind ja das ist nun richtig
wertvolles gerät ja und auch hier muss
ich sagen nicht schlecht wobei der hier
besser als ruhig mal hier um einen
anderen ringfinger zeigefinger aber das
hier ist der ringfinger gehabt ein
junger eltern
jetzt sollen einer kommen mich fragen
wie viel ist ein auto fährt dem erzähle
ich habe zwei jahren glaub ich oder als
würdest du sagen sehr gut und leute ich
weiß das video ist ein bisschen reggae
bis hin also ich habe bessere wie ich
muss sagen was war so aber hier haben
wir noch das nächste gold produkt und
das hier geht es halt irgendwie
vielleicht auch ne sowie haben wir das
hier ist sogar noch schwerer als der
hier stehe irgendwie drauf wie viel das
ist hier steht drauf also auf dem
johnson matthey feingold 9999 und hier
steht 900 99,9 eine unze ach ja genau
uns sagt man ja zu einer unze gold also
das steht hier auch drauf also stelle
ich mal bei den u11 lexar also ich sag
mal so fand ja wie schon gesagt an
unsere goldexperten schreibt man die
kommentare was haltet ihr davon kann man
das tragen oder nicht ich würde es
persönlich nicht tragen
wobei ich diesen geringen ganz neues
findet also die sehen beide nicht billig
aus das muss man sagen ansonsten freue
ich mich sehr auf die eis taut produkte
da haben wir auf jeden fall eine menge
sachen die deutlich cooler sind seid
gespannt drauf ich bin es auch wir sehen
uns dann morgen um 19 uhr wieder gibt es
das neue video jeden tag um 19 uhr
schreibt sich hinter die ohren abonniert
den kanal blogger aktivieren wir sehen
uns instagram alex w ach so genau ob
instagram wer diese ganzen sachen immer
verlost auch wenn's nicht teuer war die
wahl leicht trotzdem und meine story
irgendwo freut sich auch darüber
deswegen check gerne instagram abreise
elektro-pop 1